well this is what we know about Nicola
Bully's last movements she went missing
early last Friday morning after driving
10 minutes from her home in Inskip to
the nearby Village of Saint Michael's on
wire she dropped her children off at
school before heading down garstang road
with her dog Willow there she began her
walk around the river at around 8 43 a.m
at about 8 50 she was seen in the lower
field and it was around this time that a
woman wearing a red coat was also seen
and police asked her to come forward as
a potential eyewitness and she has now
been spoken to
Nicholas sent an email to her boss at 8
53 a.m at 901 she looked into a team's
call
and then about nine minutes later a
witness who knows Nicola saw her on the
upper field still with her dog Willow
at 9 30 the team's call ended but
Nicholas stayed logged on
Nicholas mobile phone and Willow were
found at a bench by the river by another
dog walker at about 9 35 A.M
so it's exactly this time a week ago
that Nicola went missing some of her
friends are now on the route that she's
known to have taken and Skye's Fraser
Ward is there instant Michael's on wire
for us this morning so Fraser explained
to us what's going to happen then this
morning
yeah there's been a huge public response
today in particular one week on to the
minutes effectively since Nicola was
last seen that's in a couple of minutes
time or so just 20 minutes uh after that
her phone was discovered and the Mystery
began that it's been a terrible time for
a family we've heard of them talking to
us about their living nightmare that
began a week ago and is still continuing
the police investigation is still
ongoing and it's been helped today by
members of the public one of the people
helping to organize that Emma White a
friend of Nicholas just tell us a little
bit first of all this is such a
difficult time for all the friends and
family how are we all coping yeah I mean
I think today has been a bit of Pinnacle
as I said it's seven days on
so the community to come out and force
today and we've got banners placards
faces of Nikki who to contact with the
CNF thing the community once again has
come out in force the community to be
doing work all week we've been we've had
organized walks and people have come out
in their drones from all over all over
the county I mean you've had an
incredible response haven't you you're
saying that around 100 people or more
today helping out today there have been
all week this is really you know really
affected people hasn't it people are
desperate to know what's happened
absolutely and and
um I think you can all relate to the
situation you're either a mother or
daughter an auntie a mummy yourself you
might have children you might have a dog
called Willow it can resonate with the
situation I think that's why it has
touched so many people but yeah again
it's that mystery of unknowns like you
said it's it's feeling Eerie now that
we're a week on
and then in 15 minutes time for Nikki to
vanish and we have no other information
of where she's gone what's happened we
can see from the numbers of people who
are trying to help what Nicola means to
people just tell us a little bit about
what's she like
um yeah I think I think that speech
volumes itself
um Nikki is just a genuinely lovely
lovely person you'll see the images of
her and that's reflected inside as well
she's not only beautiful in the outside
beautiful on the inside she's caring she
loves animals she loves nature
she loves her girls her dog her family
is a world you heard yesterday when you
did your interview
Ernie Sandy speaks to the girls his
girls as in Lou and Nikki every single
day or sees them
and then they are he so his words are
close-knit family they really are
um
and I go back to those two little girls
now missing their mummy and that's why
we're here
just anything we can get any information
we can Glee to give them that hope and
that's why we're here and there is still
hope isn't there yeah there has to be I
won't lie it's diminishing today's a
real
if I can't describe the feeling I've got
going on here there's
an artist all our other friends and
family there's the sadness there's the
heartache there's the worry there's the
what if but then mix it all up you've
got this hope in there that's so you
don't know whether you're good bad ugly
and it's so and you have to have that
out we have to carry that
glimmer that torch whatever you want to
call of hope we have no information and
that's why it's so important for you
guys to do what you do and the police
have done tremendous efforts the
community have come together for all
that work we have to have some reward
for it and I hope today's the day
for Paul for the mum and dad for the
sister and for those girls
there were there were two people who the
police specifically wanted to speak to
they have traced those two people it
hasn't moved the investigation on or so
it seems but someone might have that
little bit of information no matter how
small mike that could help and that's
what we're this is why we're out here
today enforced you've got a big blowy
wavy man you've got the banners you've
got pictures of Nikki someone might go
oh yes chiching and it's just that light
bulb moment that anything anything that
you think so small just come forward and
um 101 obviously exciting 999 we have to
in this day and age
how could someone just disappear it
makes no sense and that's that's
probably why it's captured the nation
thank you so much for talking to us I
know it's such a difficult time for you
that you're incredibly Brave to stand in
front of the camera and put that appeal
out so that is the appeal anyone who has
any information about Nicholas
whereabouts no matter how trivial it
might seem come forward it could be the
key it could be the secret uh part of
this puzzle that the police are
desperately trying to find
yeah really important appeal Fraser
thanks very much indeed for that